[Music]
[Applause]
time now for pft on yahoo sports peter
king mike florio all the big stories in
the national football league and don't
look now but the terminator is not dead
the patriots after winning four out of
five are at five hundred six and six
big game on thursday night rematch of
super bowl 53 in los angeles against the
rams patriots second game there five
days apart from sunday to thursday they
destroyed the chargers can they continue
their playoff push against the very
dangerous la rams peter
i think they can mike i mean
i'm no football gambler but i'd pick the
rams in this game even whatever the
points are i think the rams particularly
brendan staley
uh
the defensive coordinator seems to
figure out a way
every single week to frustrate the
opposition
and look it isn't the patriots offense
really that's been winning these games
you know it's defense and special teams
mostly
um
but i i you know i think staley figures
out a way
to really hem them in
uh on offense so to me i i you know that
was such a fluky game the patriots
played on sunday against the chargers
uh and i think it says more negative
about the chargers quite honestly
um but i the way i look at the patriots
now mike is
let them try to win with defense now
you know belichick has done this a lot
in his 20 years it doesn't seem they've
ever been quite as moribund
you know on offense
as they are right now but you know it's
working recently so keep it going
and we saw in that super bowl a couple
of years ago 13 to three final score the
patriots completely shut the rams down i
can't help but wonder how much of that
is
rocketing around in the brain of sean
mcvay as he tries to come up with
something to score more points than they
were able to score in a season where
their offense was much better than it is
now peter
it's a great question i mean if you're
sean mcvay right now on a short week
especially
i will bet you a lot of money mike that
in this off sweet off season this past
off season particularly with the
pandemic
sean mcvay looked at his schedule and
said i know i got a short week going
into the patriots
i am working on the patriots i bet he's
worked three weeks on the patriots at
some point during this off-season and
season combined spare day here a few
hours there
uh he'll be ready in this game the
question is will jared goff be ready you
know you just get the feeling that
there's not quite an uneasy truce
between mcveigh and goff
but that goff really
is not has not turned into the rock
solid consistent leader of the offense
that mcvay would like he's going to have
to be really good on thursday night
and goff had those two opportunities in
the super bowl to hit brandon cooks on a
play that popped wide open especially
the one in the second half which i still
think they went back to because it
worked in the first half and sprung
cooks he saw him late he threw it off
target and one of the mccords came over
and broke it up and that could have been
a championship throw for golf so a lot
is on golf peter i agree with you steve
kornacki at the big board on sunday
night had the patriots playoff
percentage at 21. that seems low to me i
know they got to play the the bills and
the dolphins still but i feel like
they're better than a one in five shot
at making it to the postseason how about
you
i do too i thought some of those
percentages were weird
you know the pro football focus
percentages were were just weird like
you know the cardinals and the vikings i
i i thought those were weird where the
cardinals having a 20 more chance you
know the giants are a little bit better
and the cardinals have to go there and
win on sunday after after being on a
three-game losing streak i i don't know
but again i agree i think the patriots
have a better than 21 percent shot
yeah if you're the steelers of the
chiefs or the bills or anyone else at
the top of the conference you hope that
it ends up the patriots not being there
you don't want to face them in single
elimination time that's it for now we'll
see you next time for more pft on yahoo
sports have a great day
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports